le projet de loi que je vous présente
est exceptionnel je vous propose en
effet d'instaurer la démocratie a et
coll nous représentons 98% de la nation
scolaire mais nous sommes le tiers état
de l'école le parlement des enfants
c'est une journée absolument magique
j'allais dire pour les enfants comme
pour les adultes
tout est fait pour que l'assemblée
nationale le temps d'une journée
devienne un paradis pour les enfants
alors dans les jardins de la cei il y à
pas mal de stands beaucoup de choses à
manger c'est un peu charlie et la
chocolaterie ici pour avoir la chance de
visiter l'assemblée nationale d'être
l'espace d'une journée
de vrais petits députés question pour un
député comment s'appelle le président de
l'assemblée nationale claude bartolone
combien il y a deux députés dans
l'assemblée nationale 577 le but
évidemment c'est de sensibiliser tous
les petits élèves de cm2 à la question
de la citoyenneté à la démocratie nous
allons examiner les quatre propositions
de loi sélectionnés par le jury national
j'ai représente la classe de chats dans
l'aube et nous sommes honorés de
défendre notre proposition de loi la
proposition de loi de ma classe
traite de la violence qu'on l'ait un
sujet universel
nous voudrions que les adultes nous
aident à ce que tous dès le plus jeune
âge comprenions mieux les différences
entre filles et garçons et que nous
soyons ainsi réellement égaux en droits
et que nous ayons accès aux mêmes
chances j'en appelle donc à vous et
coller de france si vous aimez la
démocratie est de votre devoir de
soutenir ce projet de loi voté pour la
proposition de loi numéro 2 je vous en
remercie
c'est pas du théâtre les enfants
travaillent vraiment au cours de l'année
scolaire de cm2 et dépose véritablement
un texte et s'il est valable s'il peut
s'intégrer dans un texte de loi dans un
article eh bien ça arrive ça arrive et
c'est arrivé par quatre par quatre
reprises au cours des 23 dernières
édition du parlement des enfants est
arrivée en première position avec 269
voix
la proposition de loi numéro 3 dix ans
après
le jeu need lcp ça a été d'en faire un
événement télévisuel c'est un véritable
exercice d'éducation civique en live
[Musique]